20 mai 2020 le canard enchaîné publie un
article qui révèle l'intention du groupe
renault de fermer quatre sites en france
parmi eux la fonderie de bretagne
fraîchement rénové après un incendie une
trahison pour ses 350 salariés alors que
le groupe automobile obtient au même
moment un prêt de l'état de 5 milliards
d'euros pour surmonter la pandémie très
vite le 22 mai 2001 l'usiné bloquée par
un mouvement social
une semaine plus tard un accord est
validé entre les syndicats et
l'entreprise qui assure conserver sous
son égide le site breton
mais le tour de montagnes russes ne fait
que commencer le même jour renault
annonce un plan d'économies de plus de 2
milliards d'euros sur trois ans avec à
la clé la suppression de 15000 emplois
dans le monde dont 4600 en france le 11
mars 2021
renault annonce à nouveau son intention
de vendre le site faisant fi de toutes
les aides et promesses fin avril usine
est à nouveau bloqué désabusé les
salariés ont du mal à trouver les mots
nous on a fait des efforts pendant un an
maintenant ça serait bien qu'ils aient
leurs côtés fassent leur avec un petit
effort vous gardiez pense que c'est
vraiment des venins pour pouvoir enlever
cette boîte qui passerait de marché dans
terminer la course à ce raid ventes
passent outre les ouvriers je pense
qu'il mérite pas ça mais goûter
dégoûté blasé on sent trahi une fois de
plus quoi tout ce qu'on attend c'est
qu'ils les actes c'est à dire qu'on
reparte sur les bases qu'on était censé
arriver nous donner du volume nous
animer travail par rapport à ce qu'elles
étaient mis en oeuvre commence à être à
bout quoi à bout de patience et de
confiance au problème
aucun repreneur ne se manifeste alors
que renault continue de délocaliser ses
fonderies pire le site breton est à
peine évoquée lors du tour de table avec
les syndicats
les différents syndicats étaient invités
ce monsieur martinez c'est la seule
personne en fait qui à café de bilan un
peu des fonderies en france et le
secteur automobile
donc c'est les seuls en début de séance
en fait il était 3e et la avoir parlé en
fait les gens n'ont pas du tout parlé
d'un faut que le mental
après quarante jours de mobilisation des
salariés et incitent fortement ralenti
renault a annoncé vendredi soir la
signature d'un protocole de reprise
d'activité de la fonderie de bretagne et
s'est engagée à augmenter le volume de
production de 10% en 2021
de leur côté les salariés demandent à
rester dans le groupe renault est le
retour à caudan des volumes de
production délocalisée à l'étranger